hey guys welcome back to the game's bud
stage here at e3 2016 brought to you by
airheads bites today Scott Butterworth
and I are joined by Nick who's a
producer on gravity rush to anti Amazon
who is the game director thank you so
much for joining us thanks for having us
what has the reception been like to the
trailer that they dropped on Monday oh
it's been insane I love the fact that
people are so into it I mean I think it
just really pops off the screen you know
the the team has built gravity rush to
to like from the very beginning to be a
ps4 game right so taking advantage of
that making all the you know animation
in the world just so much bigger and
having so much more stuff going on it's
been amazing to watch and the team has
just been cranking on it for four years
now so everything that we're seeing is
just the beautiful like product that
they've been you know bringing to life
so I'm getting constant tweets about it
I love it all the love like kind of
powers us to keep doing our jobs better
so cuz it's so nice to hear there's been
an outpouring of positivity because so
often it's kind of the opposite so
that's great that everyone's been so
like it ya know it's video games you
think more positivity I mean if there's
any week to be excited about games at e3
Mike Riley how many time to be like
excited about we do this would be the
time and I will say the game is looking
really beautiful such a colorful game
and it's really great to see it so
vividly conveyed yeah on the ps4 on the
big screen so longer like I mean cuz I'm
ever playing gravity rush originally on
the Vita yep so it's so great to see it
come so far and become this huge lush
just like visually splendid experience
yeah absolutely I mean that the team was
trying really hard to bring you guys
like a much bigger you know expansive
game I mean open-world action through
that awesome japanese and also like
franco-belgian comics like lens right
like nothing looks like gravity rush and
yeah the color palette is just extreme
in this one right the first one lots of
greens lots of Browns right now we have
lots of Blues lots of like you know all
sorts of colors just you know going at
once here I would say the world is very
it's such an unusual mix I mean like you
said the sort of European stylings but
also like weird little steampunk touches
and obviously some you know players of
Japanese culture throughout that was
wondering if you talked about sort of
like maybe the research or even just the
art that
inspired the world were saying to the
inspiration hi chato system promotion so
des nano moto moto Freya nanograms
non-comic robando designee cosas de
thandi skade oh so konna boku kodomo no
poor castrato yo no te animas oh yeah
Connie khone KO sri Carano Maggie Romo
no no eco tota soy como no denville
mixture verdad oh no dad gravity ratio
no Sokka Sokka no mutiny constable Tokyo
Satan day sunny Mexico como no habito so
des Nieto la Mosca tawdry me kiss pony
Terry Otto Asano euro Anatomy Nicco Sky
Go kitano desk 00 so pokhara okay tehee
no gas over sigma sub sub so do our
research going to to Mexico to Asia a
lot of like very very beautiful
environments that you're seeing really
look like it here they're in this new
area called jirga parallel it's very
much inspired by Central America and
stuff like that so that market that we
saw in the beginning was very much you
know a reflect reflection of that you
saw people juggling you might have seen
animals like running along the ground
there doing so much more now than they
could have with the original vida sure
that uh you know they're just delighted
to bring it to you guys here and the map
in the game is actually two and a half
times bigger than you leave in Game two
so if you thought the first one was a
pretty big experience like you're in for
so much more with every Rush teams
actually on that somebody can you
comment on sort of the structure of the
game and how open it is or how it will
compare to the way the first game of
structure yes so I mean you're gonna
find a very similar structure in here
you'll be going from area to area like
eventually getting access to everything
at once but you know the whole idea is
that you're shifting gravity you're
falling from place to place nothing's to
cut off from you and we're actually
giving you new ways to traverse that
environment what we're seeing right now
is the lunar style it's a new gravity
style you access by flicking up on the
DualShock 4 touchpad it lets lets cat
actually zoom towards her enemies with
this wormhole kick that we're seeing and
it lets her just kind of zoom and flies
shield I've off here and she'll be able
to get to her next location you know
almost the Superman type dive like that
and teleport so I mean we're really
upping the arsenal here in terms of what
you can do we'll see a new style in just
a few moments as well but very much open
world
very much the the structure that you're
expecting you know so if you play
gravity rush 1 if you play the remaster
that released in February over here
you'll be very much at home with what's
going to be happening it's so soon go
home so I was going to say it's so
interesting of gravity rush almost like
a superhero game I never thought of in
those terms before yeah it kind of is an
innocent yeah and and cat is a very
unique hero you know she kind of had the
responsibility thrust upon her you
played the first game you know she saves
a little boy at the beginning but his
house comes crashing down and people are
upset at her so you know you can see
whenever she shifts gravity or does
things it has unintended consequences
sometimes so her growing into that hero
that that we know she is as a big part
of the story and it's a big part of the
story in this one I've question for toy
amazon obviously he's known for being
one of the key creatures behind silent
hill and siren how much of a departure
from that obviously the game is
completely different what was that like
in terms of creative mind shift really
know what i did but i cannot right
through me let's go to be funny
conscious Tara who you finna go check up
on 0800 moto moto excreta katana sake I
can toast echo in August Arizona create
OC go to toast a poor on Jupiter hace
daño spoke i Dragutin dere na tchuto so
no ma e Ziggy natano des animaux casket
Otto Nita interestin apply so this is
always the kind of title that he wanted
to create Nene obviously had a lot of
success with horror titles back in the
day but this is really you know
something he's been wanting to realize
and and and kind of bring to life for a
long time so in terms of like shifting
back and forth to it I don't really
think it took too much because it's
always kind of been within him always
something he wanted to do so you're
really just seeing something brought to
light here that's you know something
they wanted to manifest for a long time
what was he was there any key moment or
any key thing that he saw that inspired
the it's obviously a very unique
gameplay mechanic yeah I mean we've we
talked about this a lot for you know
being able to so there's a there's
actually a very famous comic by Mobius I
don't know if you're familiar he's a
he's the one that kind of created these
like bandy dezzy and I'm Bo
the French style of franco-belgian
comics right in a very famous one called
link Hall which is of sci-fi comic and
it's all about like kind of falling and
gravitational ships and stuff right now
so there's a lot of influence of that on
display over here and then adding to
that there's like a dash of manga he's a
big fan of tow a I'm not sure if you're
familiar that company they make like
Sailor Moon and like lots of feminine
hero characters right so you can
definitely see that in here as well
right so it's really kind of all those
things coming together and realizing
this you know it's bright beautiful
gaming you know we've been seeing a lot
of little sort of story exchanges just
like conversations happening with like
someone's face popping up and a little
text popping underneath is that how most
this were we conveyed will there be cut
scenes as well we're going to talk about
just sort of the way that story will be
conveyed of course the experience of
course so yeah lots of the story is
going to be in that same kind of comic
format because we are you know playing
Oh Maj dream to those like you know
comics of yesteryear so you are going to
see that you'll be able to to shift
around the controller to get a better
angle on things but then you know you
will see some stuff animated as well
we'll see uh you know a scene come up
coming up here in just a moment that
will kind of show you I'm talking about
my remember the flashy finishers that we
had in the first grab yes yeah they're
definitely in here and what we're seeing
right now actually is his cat and her
rival Raven from friendly rival we met
in the first game she's actually joining
you for these fights to help you out you
know whenever you have trouble so if
someone's grief EU or you know if you
can't get quite to somebody she'll help
you out she'll team up with you for
certain attacks very telling us this
co-op in the game is that as well it's a
pretty much AI controlled it is still
that single player experience and we
really want to emphasize that just
because that's what players are
expecting it's all about cats story so
you're going to be controlling cat in
the game but she's there to help you you
can see she was helping you wind up
there they're they're taking out this
huge boss and scale is just gonna be
unbelievable in this one
too thanks to the ps4 I mentioned those
those business finisher you're talking
about yeah weather always plans for a
sequel I mean a couple of complaints to
the first game was that the the story
kind of tailored off at the end but it
left the scope for the sequel was that
always planned or was it all the gravity
rush become just a success right so the
they had their their complete story
completely before they did the first
game they got through about half of it
in the first game and then you know
quickly wanted to get the second part
out of it but you know when they were
figuring out what they could do with ps4
it just took a little bit longer to get
all of that out there but yes it was
always a complete story so we're seeing
the second half of it basically the
second big part of it with the sequel
that people been waiting for so i think
it is actually a really fast anything
about this game that it started this
series started as a vita game and now
the the sequel officially is is a ps4
game so it's jumping from the handheld
to console already talk I mean you've
already touched on some subject but if
you could speak a little more to the
changes that needed to be made and sort
of the challenges that the the team
faced in bringing it to a full console
experience um it's just you know with I
think with ps4 people have always
expected you know big amazing
environments you know they expect a lot
to be going on so they did their best to
bring all that to the table you know you
go into an area with people they might
you know they acknowledge you you know
they'll kind of get out of the way
there's little touches you know Kat will
I kind of tuck in her knees when she's
flying by something you know it's it's
all the little things that I think
people are expecting you know when you
think about a big ps4 game right but
then the scale you know just something
bigger something that you just can't
experience anywhere else that's really
what they wanted to do here and you know
if if any of you haven't played the
remaster it's a great primer for getting
into this as well right all those
controls translate so well to a
dualshock 4 and if you've experienced it
on there you know it's amazing you can
still control her with the with the gyro
in the middle controller you'll be right
at home here no it's an exact same
control
with the exception I feel like this is I
mean maybe a bad idea but have you guys
thought about VR because I feel like the
idea of falling through gravity like
that mechanic might translate in a
really cool way to VR yeah you don't
throw up yeah actually I was I was with
the team in japan when they were showing
off a little bit VR stuff they were
doing the game is purposely meant to be
a little disorienting you know if you're
ever d-rush right you're hanging on top
of buildings and it's it's also very
intense in in any kind of your situation
sure um so there isn't exactly n EV are
specific stuff for this game Oh Thomas
has told me that he's personally very
interested in VR would like to do
something but you know no there's no
concrete plans at this point you know
that's a something to be decided in the
future but would definitely be very
interesting concept for gravity rush i
think obviously tyoma son has been in
the industry for a long time created
some fantastic games but he says Gravity
Rush is is the story you wanted to tell
what kind of highlights from the
development can you talk about an old
mom oh no that's because they were I
know you could scan all on omoshiroi
data recovery mustache O'Connor grab
Tina crunch time yeah totally Hassan so
disarray I know McIlroy toka toka an oak
I had steeper tacchini Korea ichiban me
Dutch master he's on non-porous canna 80
to be nice Afrika Bambaataa great 80
come on come on rock a hurry tonight
okay dahhh no dahhh be moto day i did on
this girl yeah i had her eye on a
stuffed animal teeth no Annika come come
ova Antonio know that I got a so not
very high do not yeah so the you know
just the step is always working like
really really hard to do you know
everything they possibly can you can't
say too much about you know things from
from back and forth there without like
really consulting with them too much but
you know being able to really like fly
around and like fly through those like
clouds and stuff that you see in the
ground and making it come to life is
like something that you know it's been
really amazing for him so yeah that
whole sense of gravity and making it you
know be realized that's what
so you know fact they could do that is
something that they're really proud of
so yeah I mentioned that's gotta be
pretty challenging to design something
that mean is it's not super intuitive I
mean you're doing something that I mean
as you said it feels somewhat
disoriented so I imagine finding a way
to balance that while creating the game
like well you know how how does right
things to disorienting yeah that has to
have been a pretty serious design
challenge yeah yeah and we you know we
passed builds back and forth a lot and
and talk about what's too much and
what's too little and you know what
people are expecting versus you know
what what we can really deliver to them
and you know and trying to make sure
that we're giving something that's fun
and exciting and a new and fresh that's
not like anything else out there it's a
long process and this one's been you
know as I said it's been a fuse the
making and sometimes great things take
time so we're really happy to bring it
here it's on the show floor you know and
it's going to be out this year so people
are finally getting the chance to see
the end of cat story and we're again
we're really so it's just at the end of
cat story earlier I'm curious so yeah
you said so is this the the final game
zone cat there's a quick more gravity
rush after this what we're billing this
is the conclusion to cat story whether
that story that they wanted to tell the
one that started with gravity rush is
going to find a conclusion here as an IP
really can't say you know you never know
where things might take us but if you're
looking for a nice conclusion to two
cats story if you want to find out where
she came from what's with all these
powers what's going on it's all here in
gravity rush to we'll go deep on that so
awesome Nikki set us out later this year
later this year oh do you ever really
state yet not yet just 20 2016 point 16
it's definitely out this year and we'll
be able to tell you a lot more in the
upcoming weeks so well thank you to you
and to amazon for joining us guys for
more III coverage of course make sure
you stay tuned to gamespot com
you